THANKS, EVERYBODY.
HAVE A GOOD DAY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
ALEXANDRA COLLIER CORTEZ
LECTURING US ABOUT THE WEATHER
TODAY.
FLASH CARDS ON MONDAY.
ACT OF GOD?
NO, IT'S THE FAULT OF
REPUBLICANS NOT PASSING HER
GREEN NEW DEAL AND NOT GIVING
HER FULL POWER OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
ONE PROBLEM ABOUT THAT,
SCIENTISTS DISAGREE WITH HER
READ ON THAT.
WE'LL TALK TO HER HEAD.
HERE'S A QUIZ.
HOW MANY FOREIGN NATIONALS ARE
LIVING IN THE UNITED STATES
RIGHT NOW?
KIDDING, IT'S A TRICK QUESTION.
NOBODY KNOWS THE ANSWER.
COULD BE 10 MILLION, COULD BE
50 MILLION BIT WE WOULD JUST BE
GUESSING.
PRETTY EMBARRASSING FOR AN
ADVANCED COUNTRY TO KNOW WHO
LIVES WITHIN ITS BORDERS, BUT
HONESTLY WE HAVE NO IDEA.
THE LAST ORACLE YEARS, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATIONS TRYING TO FIX
THAT BY INCLUDING A SIMPLE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION ON THE 2020
CENSUS.
DEMOCRATS HATE THE IDEA, OF
COURSE.
IF VOTERS ACTUALLY KNEW HOW MANY
NONCITIZENS LIVED IN
UNITED STATES, THEY MIGHT BE
LESS THAN ENTHUSIASTIC GIVING
FREE HEALTH CARE TO ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
LAST MONTH, LIBERALS ON THE
SUPREME COURT THREW UP
ROADBLOCKS TO THE CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION TO THE SENSES
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
CONFIDENT IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> WE'VE BEEN CONSIDERING ALL
THE OPTIONS BEING IN CONSTANT
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE PRESIDENT
SINCE THE SUPREME COURT DECISION
CAME DOWN.
THE NEXT DAY ARE TWO, YOU'LL SEE
THE NEXT APPROACH WE ARE TAKING.
I THINK IT PROVIDES A PATHWAY ON
GETTING THE QUESTION ON THE
CENSUS.
>> A LARGE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
AGREE WITH THAT.
SO DOES THE UNITED NATIONS.
THERE IS NOTHING INHERENTLY WE
ARE CONTROVERSIAL ABOUT ASKING
WHO WAS A CITIZEN OF THE
COUNTRY, EVERY NATION HAS A
RIGHT TO KNOW THAT.
TEN PREVIOUS CENSUSES HAVE ASKED
ABOUT CITIZENSHIP, BY THE WAY,
INCLUDING THE LONG FORM CENSUS
IN 2000 BACK WHEN BILL CLINTON
WAS PRESIDENT, THAT WAS LESS
THAN TEN YEARS AGO.
NOBODY CLAIMED THAT IT WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE IT WAS
NOT UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND STILL
NOT THEIR CONSTITUTION HAS NOT
CHANGED BUT WHAT HAS CHANGED IS
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SUDDENLY THEY ARE TELLING US
THAT IT'S ILLEGAL FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO ASK IF YOU ARE A
CITIZEN OR NOT.
WHY?
YOU KNOW WHY.
THE SAME REASON THEY GAVE FOR
OBJECTING TO EVERYTHING.
IT'S RACIST!
SPEAK OF THE CITIZENSHIP
IS MOTIVATED BY RACIAL AND
PARTISAN REASONS.
IT'S NO PURPOSE IN SOMETHING
THAT IS NEUTRAL, ALSO FORCED.
>> THIS IS POLITICAL MOTIVATION.
THIS IS VERY RACIALIZED BUT YOU
DO NOT WANT COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE BEING REPRESENTED IN THIS
CHAMBER EQUALLY.
THIS IS NOT WHETHER OR NOT I
WANT TO KNOW WHO IS A
CITIZEN IN THE UNITED STATES OR
NOT.
I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THE RACISM
AND THE VERY DISTURBING HISTORY
THAT WE ARE SEEING HERE.
THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO KNOW.
>> THIS IS ABOUT KEEPING -- YOU
KNOW, THIS HAD?
MAKE AMERICA WHITE AGAIN.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE SUCH
LIARS.
AT SOME POINT, WORDS LIKE THESE
LOSE THEIR POWER AND THEIR
MEANING.
THEIR MISUSE IS ABSURD.
BUT IT'S ALSO ENTIRELY FAKE,
LIKE THE TEMPER TANTRUMS.
DO WHAT I WANT OR I WILL CALL
YOU A RACIST!
IT'S ALWAYS THERE THREAT.
HOW LONG WILL PEOPLE FALL FOR IT
QUESTIONING HOW LONG WILL
REPUBLICANS IN PROGRESS BE
INTIMIDATED BY IT?
THERE IS NOTHING RACIAL ABOUT A
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION, OBVIOUSLY.
A QUESTION WOULD APPLY TO
EVERYONE WHETHER THEY ARE HARD
DOORMEN, NORWEGIAN, CONGOLESE OR
KOREAN.
IT'S LITERALLY COLOR-BLIND.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IS NOT